ما تزال حادثه الصواريخ التي سقطت على
بولندا امس تسقط سيلا من الاتهامات بين
طرفي نزاع الروسي والوكرانيا رئيس
الهولنديه اعلن في البدايه ان بلاده ليس
لديها اي دليل ملموس حول مطلق الصاروخ
الذي انفجر في قريه قرب الحدود الاوكرانيه
لكن بعدها بساعات عاد ليقول لان الصاروخ
الذي سقط على اراضي بلاده اوكرانيا شارد
بعد قيام الدفاعات الجويه في الاوكرانيه
بمحاوله تحييد هجوم الروسي
روسيا زازا
اوكرانيا الدفاع الجوي والاوكراني اطلق
الصواريخ لتحديد هذا الهجوم الروسي تشير
تقديرات الى انه تم اسقاط النصف الصواريخ
الروسيه وربما اكثر وضرب الباقيه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لسوء الحظ من المحتمل جدا ان
يكون احد الصواريخ التي اطلقتها الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه قد سقط على اراضينا
والارجح انه لم يكن الان
لكن من المحتمل لانه كان انفجارا للوقود
المتبقي فيه ربما يكون صاروخ اس 300 صنع
في الاتحاد السوفياتي وهو صاروخ قديم ولا
يوجد دليل على انه مطلق من الجانب الروسي
كبير بغرض التصعيد الخارجيه الروسيه دفعت
اذن باستدعاء السفيره الهولندي
ان حادثه بولندا رساله الى روسيا او رساله
من روسيا الى قمه العشرين مجددا التاكيده
على ان صاروخ الذي استهدف بولندا
روسيك التقرير المسائي الذي قدمه لقائد
القوه الجويه شخصيا وكذلك الى القائد
العام ليس لدي شك في انه لم يكن صاروخنا
ليس لدي اي سبب للشك بهم فنحن نخوض الحرب
معا من فضلكم دعونا نزور الموقع سيكون هذا
عادلا اعتقد انه من حقنا ان نكون هناك
واظهرت صوره للشرطه البولنديه حفره بجوار
مركبه مقلوبه في موقع الانفجار في بوزيودو
الصوره تبرز اثار الصاروخ الذي سقط على
منشاه حبوب البولنديه مما اسفر عن مقتل
شخصين وهو الحادث الذي اثر قلقا عالميا من
ان حرب اوكرانيا يمكن ان تنتقل الى
البلدان المجاوره